hello everyone and welcome back to
championship showdown we are continuing
with uh
a game from round four it's a gary
caspar versus fabiano caruana and two of
them already played uh
well quite a long match uh in 20 2019
also in chess 916 because kasparov got a
lot of winning positions but
he was always low on time but this
tournament he's doing much better on
time so let's see how he does against
fabi
uh as this is also quite quite the
thriller so without further ado let's
check it out and here uh kasparov with
the white pieces
opens with c4 and there was a lot of
talk about uh
how you would open as here you can see
you have the the two bishops here
uh all the way on the queen side you
have the knights on the king side and
i thought before the game that i would
play b3 and c4 that that would be good
because the bishops are here and that's
how
kasparov opened so i was feeling very
good about myself even though he opened
with c4 first
i thought maybe maybe b3 and then c4 but
all in all i did enjoy it so here uh
fabi does the same with c5
and b3 of course it makes sense to open
up your bishop pair
since the king is here and he's probably
going to castle kingside so it does make
sense
b6 fabi does the same and knight the g
to f3
uh fabi goes uh with the other knight
knight e2 f6 and now
d4 by kasparov uh grabbing the center
also d5 might be an idea so fabi
prevents it with e6 and here because
power of just castles
uh uh this video we're going to skip how
you castle in chess 960 as i think now
pretty much all of you are up up to it
uh we have knight to e7
and now uh queen to d2 so just
developing uh harmoniously
knights the g6 and knight to d3 by
kasparov
uh we have queen to e7 and here rook
after d1 and casparo was doing
uh very very poorly on time up until
this point
five was like 18 minutes on the clock
and casparo was on 10 so kasparov burned
almost half of his time already
c captures on d4 fabi trades in the
center we have knight captures and
now a king said castle for fabian here
we have a
pretty normal positions with both
players having a really awesome bishop
pair something we don't see very often
in regular chess
uh there you have it that's a weird
arrow but uh what are you gonna do
uh and here queen to b4 kasparov goes
for this queen trade to increase
activity of his knights and fabi
declines it
here he goes uh bishop to d6 he pushes
back kasparov's queen
queen back to c3 and now rook after e8
uh we have knight to b5 now pushing back
uh fabi's bishop
bishop back to b8 and now again queen to
before again kasparov offers a queen
trade
but now uh there's a problem if i played
the d6 here but there is
actually a free pawn uh action happening
here bishop captures an h2 is a free
pawn
because if kasparov would capture at the
knight g4
is just a winning for uh for her uh
fabi if you go up the board of course
it's mating one queen to h4 is checkmate
and if you go down the board it's not
much better king g1 you're just going to
get queen to h4 and now it's uh
it's a very tough position to play uh in
fact it's a losing position for white
so after bishop captures an h2 caspar
would just have to move the king and it
would be a free pawn for fabi
uh fabi not upon grabber as it would
seem goes
d6 uh and uh kasparov goes f3 to
service some additional protection from
the uh from the bishop pair from hell
we have a6 uh getting knight uh getting
rid of that very strong knight
uh knight to d4 and now a5 pushing back
even the queen we have queen
all the way back to e1 and now d5
uh fabi busts open the center and he
wants to
trade some rooks along the c file so
kasparov says not a problem
we have captures on the e5 knight
captures and now
rook caltras and c8 we have rook
captures and rook to c1
kasparov also very happy to trade uh uh
the other pair of rooks but here fabi
plays
rook to d8 he avoids the trade of the
second rook uh as
there are some targets along the d file
but also uh kasparov's queen
isn't doing all that much if you look at
these two knights fabi has
these knights are controlling all of
these squares the bishop controls g3 and
it's very hard for kasparov's queen to
find an active square on the board
so here kasparov tries to activate his
pieces along the c
file knights the c6 of course fabi has
to capture if he doesn't want to
lose the exchange uh we have bishop
captures on c6
rook captures and now uh fabi uses this
opportunity to go
uh to go uh deeper into the position
with a queen
at all the way to g5 uh here we have g3
blocking this uh it would be very
dangerous not to play g3 here because
there are
so many so many threats here with this
bishop on this beautiful diagonal
there's a g3 by kasparov and now well
you could go queen e3 check
uh doesn't really do anything you can
just block it with queen to f2
you could put a knight there also a very
nice idea the knight on e3 is very nice
but fabi goes for h5 instead he wants to
play h4 and bust open the position
uh so queen to c1 because part of
expecting a great attack now offers a
queen trade here
going to c1 attacking the queen on g5
and fabi goes back he says i would
much rather play h4 bust open the
position and try to go for some sort of
an attack here
and now look the c8 kasparov again wants
to trade pieces and fabi continues with
his attack with
h4 and now f4
now by kasparov completely numbing out
this uh
dark square bishop so if captures you
can simply capture not much is happening
here
so bishop to d6 by fabi uh and
now comes queen to c6 uh just
increasing the activity of kasparov's
pieces also queen to a8 might be an idea
putting pressure on the rook here
so fabi preparing for that goes queen to
f8 and now also puts a pressure there's
a double attack on the rook here
and now kasparov has to trade we have
captures captures and
now queen to c4 because powerful goes
back
and now bishop back all the way to f8
kasparov still has the bishop pair
and the fabi needs this bishop here to
help out
with the defense so you don't have any
tricks here by maybe going queen d4 and
putting some pressure on the g7
this way everything is nice and you
don't have anything to worry about and
here
a reasonable idea for kasparov is knight
to f2 uh with the threat of bishop
captures here you would ruin black's
pawn structure and
it's not all that easy for this knight
to to find
some sort of a square if the knight
moves then you might have some
uh problems alongs along this diagonal
but here caspar played bishop to d4 and
he gave
fabian an opportunity of a great
tactical shot so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this tactical shot
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
beautiful tactical shot uh and for those
who
just want to enjoy the show it's b5 b5
as now kasparov put his bishop on d4 and
if the queen moves there could be some
nasty discoveries happening over here
and it's a really really crazy line
queen captures on b5
knight captures on f4 and now what do
you do here
uh well uh you could do a lot of things
but if you just capture then
you you allow your pawn structure to be
ruined and the black will recapture the
piece
so you're gonna go b6 attack the queen
while the knight is hanging
uh knights the h3 check king to g2 and
now even queen to a8 with checks
sacrificing a piece king captures on h3
and now queen to h1 with a completely
crazy position where
kasparov would be up a piece but his
king would be on h3
and it would be well it would be very
very hard to hold this with the white
pieces even being up a piece
so that's what happens if you spotted
the b5 tactical shot but fabi didn't uh
find it or rather he did but he wanted
to improve it with h3
however h3 doesn't improve it as
kasparov immediately plays knight to f2
ah so this is now a very weak pawn and
kasparo will claim it
fabi does play b5 now but now kasparov
just goes back queen to d3 but here
kasparov should have captured on b5
because now it's a completely different
story now knight captures here
uh doesn't run into the same idea
because of e3
and now this is defended this is still
being threatened and also you cannot go
knight to check the queen covers that
so while you once you move the knight
then you play bishop captures on g6
captures and you get this position where
fabi's pawn structure is completely
ruined kasparov will claim the h3 pawn
and he will retain a much better
position
so that was possible however kasparov
goes back to d3 he has some ideas along
this diagonal
uh so knight to b4 by favi attacking the
queen also duping has to keep an eye on
the bishop here so queen e4
and now queen to c7 by fabi and here
kasparov
of course now uh as the
queen the c1 check is being threatened
uh you cannot allow this as the pawn
guards the square
you have to capture the h3 pawn so this
is what kasparov does
and now knight to d5 by fabi uh and here
kasparov is
pretty much winning but
here is where things get really
interesting and here is where
well uh something happens and something
that we're all gonna have to get
used to happening uh now that you know
chess is pretty much an online thing uh
so here comes power of could go knight
g5 and it's uh it's a winning idea
because there's the threat of knight
captures on e6 captures you're gonna be
able to capture this knight
or just captures captures captures with
check depending on what black plays
so here with best defense which is
bishop to c5 now
i challenging this bishop you still go
knight captures on e6
f captures and queen captures with check
uh connecting with both knights here
king to f8 uh of course if you go there
uh there's always queen captures here
because the bishop also attacks
g6 so here queen to f5 check and now
only once the king moves uh otherwise if
you go here then this also falls away to
check
king is seven now you're gonna capture
on d5 or you could block with the knight
but then the bishop falls uh if you
block with the knight
then the queen captures on c5 as bishop
captures on c5
as both the queen and the bishop are uh
attacking it so king e7
queen captures on d5 and now bishop
captures with czech
captures and now you could go for this
queen to c1 check and
win the bishop but king f2 queen
captures and now queen captures on g7
with
check completely crazy position king
eight and now h4
sorry uh h4 uh followed by h5 h6 uh the
uh the the vast pawn majority uh will be
able to
uh you know overcome the the extra
knight
uh so this is uh what was in the
position however kasparov
wanted to play a different line kasparov
is up upon so he just wanted to play the
com queen to c2
offer a queen trade and then if fabiano
doesn't uh
go for the queen trade then he's gonna
go for the attack however casparo played
queen to d3 here and it's a really weird
move
that it doesn't really do all that much
uh but the point is
uh probably what happened here is that
caspar wanted to play queen to c2 he
he accidentally played queen to d3 but
he probably played like queen to d3
and then immediately clicked queen to c2
and then the interface remembered
kasparov's pre-move
so as soon as fabiano played uh bishop
to c5 uh the interface uh immediately
played kasparov's spree move
and here uh well kasparov played queen
to c2 and he
gave up a full bishop uh of course fabi
grabbed the bishop
and now it's kasparov is in check and of
course he was in this position
on 35 that kasparov resigned the game as
now he's just uh
you know uh bishopless well not
bishopless he does have one bishop but
a bishop perilous uh but it's a really
it's a really sad thing and caspar was a
very sad
uh you know uh it's something that we're
gonna have to get used to happening in
online chess because sometimes
uh you either drop your piece on wrong
square or you
like i think this is what happened here
because there's
uh really no reason to play queen to d3
and then of course uh
queen to c2 was played instantly so i i
do believe this was a pre-move
uh but this point it would be pointless
to continue here iran a piece and uh
well it's such a shame because it was a
really a high quality game and kasparov
had an extra pawn
uh he could have just traded down into a
very nice end game or if fabi declined
it could have been a very nice attack
so a lot of possibilities but in the end
uh the pawn slip
the mouse slip is what uh you know
uh was the decisive factor in this game
so a tough break for kasparov but uh you
know it does happen
we'll see how how this will uh you know
uh
how he will deal with this for uh for to
continue for the rest of the tournament
uh but hopefully he will he will bounce
back and
play some good chess so uh that's uh the
game i do hope you enjoyed it uh
kasparov most
certainly didn't but what are you gonna
do i would like to thank advice advaith
palace
yen yuvanan adavit kimura tyler humel
and adam repo for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the uh
champion showdown checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend